il ya toujours un sentiment partagé à
l'afrique de ses courses d'apple entre
d'un côté l'excitation de découvrir des
nouveaux produits la conf
au niveau des produits la compte que
vous avez lieu un peu plus tôt le
tabloïd bild ici c'est un peu moins
produit c'est quand même mon truc mais
tout ce qui est produit c'est toujours
un peu façon beaucoup d'ailleurs très
excitant mais à la fois hyper frustrant
pourquoi et bien tout simplement parce
que je n'ai pas la possibilité de
prendre les produits en mains tout de
suite de lézat bois et je ne peux les
voir qu'à travers mon écran à travers
une clientèle de kosyam strange aimerait
pouvoir moi secte immense est iphone on
propose promax pourquoi pas qui fait à
l'arrière d'un seul et même bloc voir
les finitions voir le travail qui était
toutefois reprendre
l'engin la bécane direct heureusement il
se rend compte du rendu final alors ça a
l'air coup ça a l'air intéressant on va
faire un point on va pas surprendre les
specs et regarder tout ce qui le relie
au niveau de ses smartphones parce que
vous le verrez beaucoup ailleurs à
sciences po si ça peut être avec le but
le but ça va être de dégrossir est de
comprendre un peu ce que nous fait apple
comprendre par rapport à ceux positionne
par rapport à la concurrence
voir un petit peu ce qui nous
annonçaient ce que apple est toujours
dans le coup et toujours visionnaire est
ce que apple en conservant cette grande
encoches se place en catégorie des
marques un peu has been
comment se positionne apple tels les
stratégies on va essayer de les coller
ça ressemble
suite
[Musique]
je vous le donne dans le mille là il est
tout de suite quelque chose comme 21h40
la construit tout à l'heure on est soir
tout va bien la voix est un peu perdue
pas trop revenus des suites de berlin de
berlines ou tu fais un peu trop la fête
ce week-end suite aly femmes mais c'est
d'ailleurs tout va bien et justement
aujourd'hui apple nous a fait son grand
numéro le plus grand numéro de l'année
montre en nous présentant ses produits
sa nouveauté dans les yeux que tous les
gars nouvel ipad plutôt cool
effectivement avec le smart cover est le
petit clavier avec apple peine si ça
c'est cool intéressant plutôt vos
produits une apple watch série 5
d'ailleurs aussi intéressante pas de
grosses nouveautés on continue à marcher
un peu sur les pas de ce conte avec la
série 4 intéressant à nouveau pris dans
la gamme
il faut renouveler pourquoi pas il ya
peut être eu qu'un petit peu what the
fuck le troc un petit peu what the fuck
c'est la réécriture des iphone parce que
je pense avoir retrouvé il ya eu
l'arrivée de l'iphone 10 l'iphone dit
c'était scarlett l'iphone ça allait
montrer le chemin pour coder de l'iphone
pour apple pour les dix prochaines
années dont il se peu creux en disant on
est en cause ça c'est quand même
relativement court on verra ensuite on
ya une année à l'iphone dit c'est cdss
max et le dise
r on ne savait pas effectivement quelle
est la dénomination cette année alors
beaucoup spéculé sur fait d'abord un
iphone c'est pas logique iphone et il
faut une pro d'autres qui spéculent sur
le fait de venir en aide à voir neuf
autres 11 et effectivement c'est ce qui
est arrivé
s'entraînant vif du sujet avec iphone
iphone ont plutôt cool moi le foot m'a
tout de suite frappé c'est le design je
me suis dit ok je trouve ça très moche
je sais pas si j'ai encore mon mon bout
de papier que j'avais de l'époque j'ai
dû y jeter parce que je vais regarder la
vidéo qui a fait une vidéo c'est apple
ne fait pas ça je trouvais que ces
espèces de carhaix son côté noir tels
que ça avait été en tout cas suggéré à
ce moment là je trouve ça assez
disgracieux pas terrible et au final
très beau temps de voir qu'apple a fait
quelque chose qui est au contraire est
plutôt bien plutôt bien et fier et
plutôt bien attaquer donc ça je trouve
ça bien fait intelligent et je compterai
que le dos du produit tel que vous le
voyez sur ce qui est là un bout de
carton et non bien évidemment un vrai
iphone j'adorerais c'est pas le cas
d'ailleurs là on est sur le modèle pro
je peux concevoir ce truc là est assez
bien intégrer assez intelligent et au
final assez harmonieux
alors effectivement ça change par
rapport à ce qu'on avait l'année
précédente on est dans autre chose mais
pour moi c'est une ponction de valeur
qui est relativement différente
différentes équipes ont coûté
intéressant donc je trouve que ce soit
sur le modèle aux classiques ou alors le
pro ou le promax eh bien je pense qu'au
final le résultat est plutôt de l'allant
j'attends quand même de l'avoir dans les
mains on en parle de ces quelques
quelques bonnes journées maintenant
parce que ils vont arriver ces semaines
à ses iphone et on va pouvoir aller
tester ensemble donc bon dans l'absolu
s'impose sans trop de problèmes le form
factor je trouve assez inchangé au final
entre le 5,8 pouces de 6,5 pouces et le
six pouces on est sur ce qu'on avait une
année en termes de ventes factor pour
garder la face à man vous avez toujours
cette encoches ça ne change pas même si
la qualité de l'écran a priori serait
encore meilleur ça bien évidemment on en
parle lors des phases de test en tout
cas l'avis technique a l'air assez
intéressante un écran encore meilleur
duo fhd plus un format un petit peu
particulier j'ai pris des notes large
évolué c'est vrai qu'ils ont sorti un
format un peu un peu bâtard la dernière
c'est déjà le cas et je voudrais sur le
modèle pro sera toujours un peu un peu
cool à la fois un peu bizarre mais why
not
soyez présents sur le 5 2 8 pouces on
est en 2004 136 par 1125 pixels sont les
seuls à faire ça sont 6,5 pouces 2688
pas 1242 pixels on est vraiment sur un
format très particulier bon c'est un peu
l'inconnu différencie toujours un petit
peu a priori un écran qui serait très
lumineux qui pour aller au wimax jusqu'à
1200 dit pourquoi pas dans l'absolu
donc mon l'écran tout cas à l'air d'être
vraiment cool on connaît la qualité des
produits apple ne doute absolument pas
que l'écran soit top
nous allons associer au niveau de
l'audio un côté très spatialisé jeter un
petit coup d'oeil
j'attends vraiment d'avoir le produit
regardez ce que vous voulez jeter un
coup d'oeil à ce qu'on aurait ici là là
là
a priori ce petit truc là là ça pourrait
être un haut parleur
si ce n'est pas le cas alors j'ai un
doute soir c'est effectivement un haut
parleur
soit ça va être un petit
si l'aja pour faire le l'autofocus je
sais pas j'ai encore un doute je suis
pas vraiment vraiment penché sur la
fiche natif sur la question mais je
pense tout cas de ce que j'ai vu lors de
la course que ce serait un repas alors à
priori en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'ils nous annoncent petit masque des
mois si vous avez la réponse en ma peau
bleue marque un banc commentaires je
vous dis un conte fall a fini et pas
très longtemps le temps de préparer sa
taille d'arrivée peut-être que je suis
un peu imprécis là dessus vous
n'entendrez pas les coeurs on verra très
activement lors des phases de test en
tout cas ce qui est sûr ce qu'a annoncé
ce qui est certain c'est que au niveau
de l'audio et bien on va voir se
remettre plus spatialisé toujours plus
spécialisés pour apporter l'immersion
l'idée c'est quoi c'est que un très bel
écran d'un sont complètement spatialisé
on arrive encore plus d'un côté immersif
divertissement pourquoi lorsque vous
avez un peu l'arcade pour le jeu vous
avez apple tv de plus pour regarder vos
films et vos séries donc on va très bien
à une directrice d'apple continue à
aller effectivement dans le
divertissement et là vous avez dit weisz
qui est très clairement orienté
divertissement mais pas que mais pas que
parce que vous avez un device qui est
orienté performances avec les nouvelles
puces à 13 bionique nous annonce être la
plus performante que sa dragonne 155
tout ça je demande à voir effectivement
vers des benchmark
on en parlera aussi d'ici quelques temps
pourquoi pas why not c'est possible un
succès qu'apple travaille extrêmement
bien une belle maîtrise au niveau de ses
puces vous avez derrière un device qui
complètement optimisé un logiciel qui
est sûre optimisé ça c'est un poste
auquel apple extrêmement fort
extrêmement puissante
donc bon ça pourrait clairement avoir un
sens donc guidy performance dit gaming
et dix personnes extrêmement fluide
smartphone extrêmement performant pour
que ça va être cool sainte-adresse
effectivement aussi je pense aux
comptables plus pros comme les objets
sur le modèle pro même si des deux les
paralyse que l'iphone 11 pro n'est pas
l'iphone que pour les professionnels et
pour ceux qui veulent un smartphone
encore plus exigeants donc ça c'est cool
beaucoup de performances une autonomie
un peuple avant j'étais un petit peu un
peu dubitatif par les annonces qui ont
été faites
du point de vue de l'autonomie je trouve
que la façon dont ça a été annoncé
ça ça me fait pas rêver en fait et là je
sais juste purement marketing parce que
sinon je pense que c'est exaltant voyez
je suis continue écrire extrêmement mal
je fais là la rentrée des classes de
monfils au cp je pense que te ferai le
tour mais d'un point de vue d'un point
de vue écriture envoyé par exemple sans
les fautes nous nous annonce l'autonomie
se prend bientôt the buck en finale dont
l'autonomie est là une heure de plus que
celle de l'iphone dit
r à la tête ailleurs ok donc il a une
heure de plus et ça c'est l'effet waouh
en fait et je trouve que ça
effectivement ça plus d'un appareil pour
l'iphone
onze pros eh bien on vous annonce que
alors c'est un peu plus what the fuck un
pas réellement mais où on est loin de là
google vous êtes par exemple sur
l'iphone onze pros vous avez quatre
heures de plus d'autonomie que l'iphone
10 aces et 50 heures de plus que
l'iphone 10 s max bon voila moi ça me
semble transcende pas comme s'annonçait
d'autant plus que l'autonomie elle
dépend bien évidemment de votre façon de
votre usage donc on est un truc qui est
un petit peu compliqué après c'est
compliqué aussi pour la marque à le
faire entendre point différenciant et
intéressant sur l'iphone 11 vous avez au
niveau de la recharge du lightning le
port light ne conservez pas d'usb cette
année chez apple et on va vers l'usb 1
pouces standard ou ça vous change pas
par contre sur le modèle pro et là ça
devient intéressant et là où on va un
peu dans le côté professionnel et on
voit qu'on voit sur autre chose c'est
qu'on a effectivement du lightning qui
se recharge sur votre smartphone mais la
côte est c'est de l'usbc on sait
notamment que les macbook pro maintenant
sont toutes en usb c'est donc là on est
sûr de les baisser comme soir l'ipad pro
on est donc sur l'usb c'est donc on va
effectivement différenciation entre la
gamme plus standard et la gamme pro
comme on peut la voir effectivement les
eaux des ipad
why not ça c'est aussi assez cool et le
dernier point et non des moindres c'est
la partie photo dans l'aston c'est
vraiment intéressant parce que alors sur
l'iphone 11 effectivement qui peut le
plus peut le moins là qui peut le moins
parce qu'effectivement on a deux
capteurs s'est pas complètement dingue
mais ça fonctionne quand je suis dans
mes notes en même temps j'ai beaucoup de
mal à me relire 68,6 montage écrit très
très très mal j'ai un peu honte vous
avez deux capteurs sur les fans 11 à 12
mégapixels avec le grand tante ou 20 f
1.8 mon caméra standard c'est l'appareil
normale et l'autre celle ultra
grand-angle pour à 120° 12 mégapixels à
f 2.4 au niveau d'ouverture bon pourquoi
pas ça me permet de faire un zoom x 0,5
travers l'ultra grand-angle bon ça c'est
pas un truc hyper 9 ans patron du foie
0,6 chez d'autres constructeurs
bon après il faut une fois de plus voir
ce qui va être rendu grâce à la puce à
13 bionique grâce aux machines learning
grâce à alain sont artificiels je pense
que c'est vraiment là que les choses
vont différent c'est parce qu'elle en
parle juste de la partie hardware mais
la partie software on arrive à être
complètement hallucinante et c'est
vraiment la tuque j'ai hâte de le tester
donc je vous invite ce n'est pas le cas
déjà vous abonner
vous saurez tout ce qu'on était très
bientôt et lorsque ce modèle pro vous
arrivez avec 3 capteur à l'arrière 12
mégapixels pareil des fins produite le
lendemain normal le téléobjectif
mesdames messieurs mais comme une fois
deux trouvera f 2.0 avec une optique
stabilisé bon why not
et vous avez toujours su très
grand-angle à 120° nos bons on n'a pas
un truc de ouf on a une optique x 2 je
crois qu'on a un zoom numérique x 4
c'est pas dingue mais en tout cas ne
sont pas dans le sont pas dans les faits
ou how come on peut avoir notamment de
chez huawei k1p 30 pro avec le port et
zoom x 10 on a pas d humus 4 x 50 x 70
on va pas apple prend pas cette
direction là je pense qu'il dise on ira
là le jour où la photo en x 50
elle sera juste top pour l'instant y
sombra je pense que la vision d'apple
c'est de se dire quand on fait quelque
chose on le fait bien c'est juste c'est
maîtrisé et on va pas sur le côté un peu
what the fuck ceo n'a plus qu'à un peu
moins de prise de risque au sens plus on
se sont extrêmement maîtrisé je penserai
smartphone très maîtrisé une ligne
directrice extrêmement maîtrisé
il n'y a pas un peu l'effet waouh qu'on
va retrouver souvent sur la course au
niveau des smartphones android c'est
peut-être ce qui me manque un peu
c'était fait un peu moins haut parce
qu'on a l'habitude aujourd'hui d'avoir
des comptes de presse notamment avec
huawei avec samsung et tout genre un peu
waouh what the fuck les smartphones
pliable les zooms fois cinq ans à 60 et
on en prend plein les mirettes
là c'est pas le cas du coup ça peut être
un petit peu dommage mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que la maîtrise d'apple n'a
absolument pas qu'elle soit extrêmement
qualitatif que vous alliez un rendu
extrêmement qualitatif et que ça va en
fait moins bien paraître gros focus fait
au niveau du modèle pro au niveau de la
vidéo 4k santé sps maximum notamment la
possibilité d' avec filmique pro de
pouvoir utiliser les deux caméras en
même temps pour filmer donc vous allez
avoir besoin de dialogue vous posez les
smartphones entre deux personnes vous
pouvez récupérer un vrai job nature et
encore et personne ne devant pas
derrière un truc vraiment hyper
performant et je ne doute pas que ce
soit vraiment rock déjà apple en terme
de vidéo est très bon et continue elle
est là dessus l'idée en fait c'est de
dire et des bouteilles
nous on a un excellent photophone on est
aussi un excellent video phone qui
s'adresse aux créateurs de contenu aussi
bien en photo sur instagram qu'en vidéo
sur
avec d'utiliser rue et surtout sur
youtube et consorts donc ça ça roule ils
ont fait un gros focus sur la photo nuit
pour se positionner face à google pixels
3 et probablement fixer le cadre des ces
quelques temps et là mon avis ils vont
chercher à faire mal à la concurrence
avec des bases solides structures est
ancré dans le sol ils peuvent marcher
donc bon why not vous dis une fois de
plus c'est un peu moi s'amuse sur sa
faim mais je suis parce que ça marchera
bien alors on va regarder à face qui est
pris presque ça c'est aussi très
intéressant comme son nom c'est l'iphone
11 au tarif de 199 dollars voilà beh
c'est extrêmement agressif
bon j'ai regardé à peu pris en euros
j'ai fait roi simplement agressifs 64
giga de sokal êtes à 809 euros sans
matière de stockage de 859 est alors
carrément 256 go de stockage être un peu
moins de 1000 euros c'est à 979 on est
un peu moins agressif donc au début je
pensais qu'ils allaient se positionner
face à des smartphones android est les
tarifs qui sont plus milieu de gamme et
au final non on est un smartphone très
très bien quand vous arrivez par contre
sur le onze pros et 11 pro mac ça fait
hyper mal je vous le fais très très
court sur le 11 pro 64 giga 1159 euros
pour commencer dans ce smartphone 256
giga 1329 512 1559 et quand vous arrivez
sur le mac cela il vous ouvre 2259 1429
1659 diack à 350 euros près vous êtes
sur un feuille de samsung c'est pas la
même chose on compare pas mais on est
son côté top innovation au club fold
hellal côté excellente innovation mais
sur un smartphone g1 forme un peu plus
standard
je trouve ça cool je trouve ça bien je
peux aussi une belle réussite une belle
avancée il n'y a pas d'effets hoarau il
n'ya pas truc où on va en parler pendant
des années mais apple continue sa route
du son chemin elle maîtrise plutôt bien
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez vous
comment est ce que vous avez ressenti
ces annonces
qu'est ce que vous pensez que cet iphone
de ses iphone de 2019
est ce que vous êtes plutôt satisfait
est ce qu a contrario vous êtes déçu
déçu de ne pas avoir le truc un peu
waouh moi je suis un peu déçu d'avoir
tout recette est grande en cochant haut
et je trouve qu'aujourd'hui ce design de
la face avant est vieillissant et
vraiment poussé sur le côté par tout ce
qu'on peut voir sur android avec lé
grand écran des caméras pop up des
caméras et tracts à tout ça tout ça se
rendre où il ya beaucoup d'innovations
sur la face avant les smartphones et là
je ne doute pas que l'écran
il ya une belle innovation dessus mais
je suis vraiment extrêmement déçu de ce
designer excellent coche parce que pour
moi on est un peu 2017 et 2019 ça me
semble un petit peu dépassé sur ça
dommage qu'apple n'ait pas cherché en
tout cas améliorer ce système
je ne doute pas une fête plus que faith
heidi prennent beaucoup de place avec la
caméra trop d'elle ce qui n'est pas
voulu en tout cas à les intérêts
d'autres techno peut-être plus tard mais
si c'est comme ça pendant des années à
mon avis le design de l'iphone à venir
encore plus vieillissant et c'est
extrêmement dommage voilà il ya un vrai
contraste entre la face avant est la
face arrière est ce que pour trouver à
l'intérieur en terme de hardware et
qu'est ce qui va se passer réellement
avec tout fonctionnement software ça
c'est un peu un peu le bémol dites moi
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire et quant à nous on se
retrouve dès demain pour parler de peu
de choses et je vous dit on et testera
très prochainement ses smartphones donc
je vous invite dès maintenant vous
abonner si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
l'ambassadeur un chao
m